hello there listeners hello there
universe hello world it's me rain wilson
here with my partner in existential
crime i'm reza aslan i am your partner
in existential crime
and we are here to talk about a
particular kind of existential crime
we're going to talk about loneliness how
to fight loneliness
whether you should even fight it what's
wrong with being lonely there's a lot
that's wrong with being lonely as we'll
soon discover we're going to find out
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
this is the topic that we thought we
would dig into loneliness is it a
universal are we meant to be lonely
are we destined to be lonely does
everyone feel lonely i would actually
seriously wonder if there are people out
there that have never felt loneliness i
doubt that there's anyone that has never
felt it i think if you can say to
yourself that you've never felt
loneliness then you are kidding yourself
like there is something psychologically
wrong with you but this comes to the the
core question right which is what's the
difference between
loneliness and being alone or loneliness
and solitude maybe because solitude is
can be a really beautiful thing it can
be creative you can get in touch with
nature and the universe and the cosmic
consciousness i mean have you okay let
me ask you this question have you ever
felt truly
lonely and i don't mean like
lonely as a positive force
you know
where you're like i'm going to take this
moment to to dig into the depths of my
soul that's who i am solitude but yeah
like actual like loneliness yes i have
loneliness
several times in my life i think one
time i felt intense loneliness was i was
living in seattle i was just starting to
go to the university of washington i was
driving a truck for ballard marine
supply hardware
and
my dad and
stepmom had gotten a divorce i was
living in my dad's basement
and i didn't really know i only knew two
or three people that i had gone to high
school and junior high school
in the area i didn't know a whole lot of
people and
i felt very angsty and extremely
lonely and bereft for months
19 i was 19. yeah so i was older but it
was also a university setting okay i was
uh i was getting a degree
and uh i was living in you know student
housing
and uh i was living with my
girlfriend fiance
you were getting your phd i was getting
my ph just say it say you were getting
you can only i was getting one of my
multiple multiple degrees
that indicate the vast level of my
intelligence
you know i felt lonely before but like
the kind of crushing sense of loneliness
that was the first time i ever
experienced it because i had moved in to
this you know campus housing with my
fiance
and uh within a week she had cheated on
me oh and yeah and left and was like was
very matter of fact about it too was
just kind of like what so i'm gonna go
and live with this other guy now and i
was like oh well that sucks
if i think back on it now
it wasn't just like depression obviously
i was depressed but it was like this
full body loneliness experience i
started having panic attacks for the
first time in my in my life where i
couldn't breathe
i didn't even know what what they were
like i didn't even know what a panic
attack was why you're having a heart
attack i thought i was having a heart
attack
as well
i think part of it had to do with the
fact that i had this idea of what my
future was going to be with this woman
and then she left and then suddenly i
couldn't see the future anymore
it was like a cosmic loneliness it
wasn't sort of literal i'm lonely right
now it was like i will be lonely forever
i don't see an end right
right
it's not a coincidence that both of us
felt our loneliest in the kind of
university college right setting there's
this uh
you know uh
study that came out from you know this
health health group cigna we all know
cigna
um
and they issued this report that
basically said the loneliest generation
in the united states yep not the oldest
americans right not the
and it's traditionally been the oldest
certainly in america because that's what
we do with our old people
shuffle them off and
let other people take care of them until
they finally die
no it's not the oldest americans
it's
some of the youngest specifically
the young adults between 18 and 22 years
old they are the loneliest generation
in america that's incredible and these
are college kids but listen this is an
epidemic around the country and
there's a special guest that uh we
really wanted to bring in dear listeners
uh varun sony who is the university
chaplain dean of religious life at usc i
was having a conversation because i
spoke there a couple months ago at usc
and he was talking about this epidemic
of loneliness anxiety
uh depression suicidal ideation that's
rampant on college campuses we thought
well there's a universal question in
here about the nature of
humanity and loneliness but he's been
experiencing it he is on the front lines
on the fight against loneliness yeah you
know funny story uh varun and i actually
went to graduate school together um at a
small liberal arts school in boston well
not really boston and cambridge uh on
the east coast school starts with an h
it's not a big deal anyway um haverford
that's it
haverford college
if anybody's familiar with cambridge
very white very white uh city
this campus was also very white and we
were two brown people similar height
both had goatees back then it was the
90s everybody had a goatee it wasn't it
wasn't just me
even
had goats it was a goatee time
everywhere we would go people would
confuse us for the other like people
would come up to me and have full
conversations with me
as though i were varun
and vice versa and it makes me think of
two things number one
god damn boston is [ __ ] racist and
number two
it was this weird thing where like
neither of us ever felt lonely
because
we kind of had this weird bond with each
other like he would literally come to me
i remember once he came to me and he's
like here's your radiohead cd back and i
was like why do you have it he said i
don't know some guy gave it to me
because he thought i was you
i was like we have this connection here
that's fantastic so please uh let's
let's bring on my friend your friend dr
varun sony
[Music]
my name is varun sony i'm the dean of
religious and spiritual life at the
university of southern california which
means i'm basically the university's
chaplain you said the first several
years you were there there were kind of
one set of issues that you were hearing
from
students about
and then that kind of shifted can you
tell us about that sure yeah when i got
there uh i had the hopes and dreams
conversations the reason i wanted to be
a university chaplain is i had these
extraordinary conversations with my
university chaplain when i was an
undergraduate i used to go talk to him
about what does it mean to be human how
do i live an extraordinary life how do i
translate my values into action what
matters to me why does it matter to me
these are questions that make us human
they connect us with everyone who's ever
lived through space and time and when i
got to sc those are the conversations i
had the hopes and dreams conversations
students were really excited about their
life their education they wanted to go
out and change the world and change
themselves but over the last five or six
years i noticed a really troubling uh
sort of trajectory in those pastoral
conversations instead of asking me how
should i live students began to ask me
why should i live
when did that start about five or six
years ago about the time when we started
transitioning between gen y and gen z i
don't want to say this is purely a
generational trend but i have seen a
noticeable difference between these
cohorts of students sometimes these are
students who are younger brothers and
sisters of millennials they were born in
the same household raised in the same
environment born of the same parents
same nature same nurture same family
same school and yet within this five or
six year period which defines this
generational shift
we began to see a lot more despair a lot
more hopelessness uh a lot more
depression anxiety so i thought it was
me i thought maybe i've been on campus
long enough that students were finding
me in a way that they hadn't found me
before but when i talked to counselors
chaplains around the country and
especially when you look at the data
it's not just what i see
it's there's no doubt that things are
getting worse and not better in terms of
stress anxiety and depression
one-third of our students are wrestling
with some kind of mental health issue 60
of college students are suffering from
overwhelming and crippling levels of
anxiety i got half my medical students
who are having trouble taking care of
themselves these are the future
caregivers of tomorrow
and uh every year it seems to get worse
what do you think is happening i mean is
it just um
the world is changing i mean some
fundamental ways i mean we talk a lot
about how
it seems like the world is increasingly
sucking do you know what i mean like
every year the suck factor of the world
increases just a little bit more i
imagine if i was in that generation and
i was looking at the way in which you
know the generations before me had
completely and totally [ __ ] the
environment
and that i was looking you know to to a
life that looked more like uh you know a
scene from dune
than anything else uh i would be
depressed too i mean is that is that i
think there's certainly that right 2008
i became the university's chaplain is a
hindu right that's never happened before
in american history how did it happen
well
2008 was a good time to be a kid with a
funny name there was hope and change in
the air right yeah students were excited
about barack obama right like it was
really good for us actually and it was
good for students even rayne wilson
has its own kind of indeterminate
ethnicity behind it oh is he from
finland
so i think there's that we are living in
the age of anxiety and outrage generally
so of course that's going to be filtered
onto college campuses anxiety and
outrage that's good i'm going to use
that there is uh you know there are
policies in place that impact college
students whether it be high tuition
whether it be daca whether it be muslim
travel ban all those things impact
college students immediately so there is
that but i don't think it's just that i
think there are other trends that are at
play here that specifically impact
generation z that haven't impacted
previous generations well one of those
is if we're looking at timelines and
you're talking about this starting five
or six years ago five or six years ago
was the advent of young people using
instagram
and diving into the instagramification
of america and i don't want to be one of
these grumpy old men that blames
everything on social media but i think
we have to look at that get off my web
you kids
your kids with your selfies and your
snapchats and your
triangle bikinis
that's i think that's a big thing listen
these are digital natives at least
millennials were born into a world and
migrated to this technology right these
are kids who are born and raised
entirely in an online social world our
kids essentially are part of this
generation we see it firsthand in sort
of our parenting and so these are kids
who have always talked with their thumbs
and not with their tongues these are
kids who
have had their most intense social
experience transpire online that makes a
big difference for 50 000 years our
species has been talking like we're
talking right now but we're telling
these kids hey this is a whole new way
of communicating a whole new way of
being a community a whole new way of
developing a tribe let's see what
happens we're in some ways guinea
pigging these kids on these technologies
and we're beginning to see what that
looks like
in terms of a longitudinal perspective i
mean this is a little bit of my grumpy
old man coming out but i kind of feel
like
this is the grand social experiment that
people will be talking about 100 years
from now kind of like remember that
generation that when they were two and a
half we gave them ipads at a restaurant
so we wouldn't have to kind of deal with
them like spilling water on the table
and whatnot and we just let electronic
devices raise these children and they
were on instagram when they were 12 and
they had phones when they were nine um
and now they've processed our bodies for
uh energy and sustenance
and
and they feed they feed off our corpses
now remember those kids there were those
kids that got really dark and they
looked like they said they live forever
they got like post matrix skynet kind of
instantly i love that about you reza but
um but yeah and i think they'll look
back and like that was insane that was
crazy that we took these children and
they're developing brains and we just
put electronics in their hands
willy-nilly without any checks or
balances on it whatsoever what's
fascinating is that you're in contact
with all these kids all the time and by
the way we should mention that usc is a
gigantic school like it's not just a so
you have a pretty big million students
yeah so you have a fairly large 140
countries 50 states you know and you're
seeing diverse communities and so this
is a global phenomenon you're seeing it
you know regardless of race or class i
see that on my campus and i assume
that's true across higher education yeah
i don't see
stress anxiety and depression of course
every person has unique histories
perspectives and identities that play
into how they navigate their own mental
or spiritual health but when you're
talking about suicidal ideation or
depression
it's an equal opportunity offender i see
it across social economic status across
national origin
et cetera et cetera
oneskin is a longevity company led by a
team of five phds developing solutions
to prevent slow down and reverse aging
one skin harnesses the science of aging
to develop products that extend the
length of time that skin is healthy and
youthful oneskin's topical supplement is
a daily moisturizer powered by their
proprietary peptide os1 the first
peptide scientifically proven to reduce
the biological age of skin milk shakers
skin care
is healthcare it's true comprehensive
wellness should include your largest
organ insert joke here no it's skin one
skin's priority is to keep your skin
healthy in order to keep your body
healthy the outstanding beauty benefits
are a consequence of a healthy skin one
skin is designed for anyone who cares
about aging at their best health and
that means men too
after all we should care again about the
health of our what reza of our biggest
organ that's right and by the way i
honestly i i swear i just used one skin
like
17 minutes ago i took a shower right
before this podcast record because i was
all greasy and it is it is delightfully
light and saturating on my face i did
notice that you look remarkably youthful
today yeah i look 37.
so um well thank you one skin i've
really enjoyed your product so visit
oneskin.commilkshake
and use the code milkshake and you'll
get 15 off your first purchase now the
code applies to one time purchases in
the first order of subscription
purchases that's
o n e s k i n one skin dot c o
slash milkshake and use the code
milkshake for 15
off your first purchase you got lots of
pets right rain i have too many pets
reza so you know pets are part of the
family well fuzzy knows there's nothing
that compares to coming home to a wiggle
butt or waking up to a soft purse and
that we want to keep our pets healthy
and make them as happy as they make us
so fuzzy folks is a telehealth service
for pet parents that offers 24 7 access
to personalized pet care from veterinary
professionals
from everyday questions to middle of the
night emergencies fuzzy has the answers
pet parents need through live chat and
virtual vet consultations available to
you 24 hours a day 7 days a week fuzzy
can answer your pet questions big and
small urgent and everyday they can also
recommend the exact right products for
your pet all of which are hand-picked by
their established team of veterinary
professionals and available at discounts
exclusive to fuzzy members so from
getting your pets diet just right to
meeting their middle of the night needs
to finally figure out what makes their
breath smell that way
for my dog it's because he eats his own
poop nothing is too big or small
for a quick fuzzy call so right now
fuzzy is offering our listeners a free
7-day trial plus
20 bucks off your first purchase of vet
recommended pet meds supplements
treatments and more all you got to do is
go to yourfuzzy.com
[Music]
and use promo code
meta to get started that's a free 7 day
trial plus 20 bucks off your first
purchase at y o u r f u
fuzzyyourfuzzy.com
using promo code
meta that's yourfuzzy.com promo code
meta
and what's fascinating is you seem to
have kind of
boiled all of these anxieties and
emotions and and everything down to sort
of this one fundamental feeling that
you're tracking in these kids and that
is loneliness that they're all just
lonely they're really really lonely
they're so lonely how does that come
across like how how does loneliness come
across in a how does it manifest
how do you hear about it so i'll give
you an example uh we just built this 800
billion dorm essentially
university village 2200 beds
and the whole idea was the architecture
would create a kind of community the way
we set it up people would be in
community with each other and the other
day a student comes to me and says our
brand new dining hall this stunning new
dining hall
can we have a table where people talk to
each other and i was like isn't that the
whole dining hall isn't that what the
dining
cafeteria is exactly and he says have
you been to the dining hall recently i'm
like no he's like if you go to the
dining hall this is a freshman pretty
self-aware if you go to the dining hall
you will see everyone on their phones
and no one has permission to talk to
each other everyone's sitting by
themselves on their phone so his idea
was let's create a table a phone free
table where people are phone free where
student ambassadors facilitate
conversations over meals where people
have permission to talk to each other
and i'm like are we seeding the rest of
the dining hall the non-talking then
this seems like a lot of work for what
should be an organic conversation i'll
go to your [ __ ] school
and i will sit at the conversation table
raza you and i can go sit at a
conversation table and be like put your
phones away let's have a conversation i
will spearhead that movement i love that
well they even know how to talk is the
question will they just sit there and be
like um
so
how many likes do you have on your when
you're interested you know it's not like
it's it's not
what i'll say about gen z is they are
very self-aware they are also trying to
be part of the solution even though they
realize that they're kind of in crisis
they're all sorts of amazing student
leaders who are kind of tackling these
issues on their respective college
campuses but we are we've got a class on
friendship now i'm on a campus with
nobel prize winners with macarthur
genius grant winners with pulitzer prize
winners and the one class that i decided
to teach was friendship 101 like how to
make a friend how do you teach
please help me so i'm not teaching the
class we direct we have someone who's
teaching it for us but it's you know
it's kind of basic social skills you
know how to read social cues how to uh
have eye contact how to uh be present in
a conversation how to ask good questions
this is astonishing to me this is
astonishing like you get course credits
this class is not for credit and yet the
waiting list is so long we can't keep up
with the demand okay yeah you can talk
about a lot of different things that are
going on that are causing these these uh
anxieties in younger people and a lot of
them you know make sense like i would be
anxious too
but fundamentally it seems like when
we're talking about loneliness the
inability to make friends it does come
down to social media it does come down
to technology it's like
the the sort of online world of fake
friends has just completely screwed
things up for these kids so that they
just don't know how to make
real friends anymore and our producer
amy sent us this really fascinating book
about sort of how technology
changes the way that we think about
loneliness and there was this passage
that i that i was reading that just blew
my mind when the phone was invented the
sort of advertising for the phone and
why everyone had to have a phone
the whole point of it was well if you
have a phone then you'll no longer be
lonely a phone will make it so that you
always you always have a friend you can
always call somebody like if you're
feeling lonely you have a friend you can
call someone and you won't be lonely
anymore it's literally this the antidote
to loneliness
and then
when people were still lonely
you know it didn't actually matter that
you could call a friend and people still
dealt with loneliness
the sort of
psychology of loneliness started to
change and it became less about
you're lonely because of your social
situation you're lonely because you know
the job that you have or the the kind of
home that you live in and instead it
became well no
you're lonely because there's something
wrong with you it's a fault like if if
you're still lonely and you have a phone
then it's because you're an [ __ ] and
nobody likes you that's the only
explanation it could also be true well
yeah so this goes to the key question is
have we always been lonely and is it
really so bad
to experience loneliness there's a
difference between being alone and being
lonely right i think there is great
benefit to having a life of solitude of
contemplation of spending time by
yourself of reflection all of us do that
it's been really beneficial i think to
our personal or professional lives to
have that space to create that space
uh loneliness i think can probably be a
driver uh in some motivating way but
what we're seeing here is i think
something different because
your young adulthood is a time of tribe
is a time of community is a time of
connection that's what you're supposed
to be doing on college campuses that's
what we did that's what you know that's
why we i think we're able to thrive in
some particular way so we need geriatric
volunteers to show up at the college
campus
and give all these college kids hugs not
smart just hugs bring their walkers
listen it used to be the other way and i
think you're onto something we can
reverse engineer this we need the
world's greatest generation
to quote tom brokaw or whoever the [ __ ]
dan rather to go on to the to usc like
free hugs from from old people please
old people do not show up on college
campuses with a sign saying free hugs
that's how they send you away
okay
this is super interesting because
college
i mean that's the that's where you you
make your closest friends that's where
your identity
starts to form you know and it's so
interesting to me that
part of the problem it seems if we are
kind of tracing it to technology and
social media and stuff that part of the
problem that these kids are having is
that they spend so much time
creating these constructed selves online
right cells that can be edited
and deleted
and you know manufactured and massaged
curious curated perfect presented in
exactly the way that you want it to be
presented
and then when you move from the virtual
realm to the real realm
and
you know you're messy and you don't say
the right things you don't get a chance
to delete and edit yourself
i could see how that would make you
unmoored it would be it would be very
difficult to make friends if there's no
filter between the two of you but
there's another aspect to this about the
online reality of today's younger
generation and that is and going back to
this question about loneliness i don't
know that i agree with you varun that
that there's a difference between being
alone and loneliness because i think
that feeling loneliness
is part of the human condition and
everyone feels lonely
for at some period of time in their life
and everyone has to struggle with
loneliness
i i did when i was younger i felt really
desperately alone even when around a lot
of people and i think that's okay
to an extent um it never got me to the
brink of suicide or to medication um but
it's part of a a spiritual
uh truth of we are alone uh we are in
these bodies we have this consciousness
floating in space kind of having the
perception of being
different and alone and you know in our
in our little meat puppet suits uh going
around the world that's part one and
part two is
what i've noticed is that because kids
can constantly be distracted so if
they're bored let's say because
loneliness goes with boredom a little
bit kids cannot stand to be bored at all
and i couldn't i hated being bored when
i was a kid and if i had the ability to
pull out a phone and to play
angry birds or watch a youtube video
instead of being bored i would have been
on it all the time
but here you have a generation of kids
that have never been
alone sat with discomfort and aloneness
and boredom and then tiptoed into a
healthy loneliness to kind of ponder
that loneliness of like i feel so alone
and i wonder if i'll ever really connect
with someone and
that's a kind of an existential crisis
of
being a human being that's right this is
oh hold on i gotta riff on this because
that is so smart
the truth is is that because of our
phones
we don't ever have to be alone ever
again
right because you've always got
something or someone friends online yeah
entertainment so diversion if you're
never alone
then you never learn
how to be lonely
then loneliness is never a good thing
it's always a bad thing and it just self
perpetuates yes i like this idea that
loneliness is part of the human
condition this is part of a spiritual
process we all have felt lonely that
helps us build resiliency there are good
aspects to all of all that right
suffering is part of the human condition
sadness etc loneliness we have to combat
that and if we don't we don't build
resiliency and i do think that even
though every year my students are more
intelligent more accomplished they're
brighter they're harder working they are
less and less resilient resilient every
year and i think there's something to be
said about that but my concern is that
at what point does it become an epidemic
at what point does it become too much
right at what point does it become
crippling or overwhelming not something
that
forges character but something that
you know causes you to drown and that's
where i'm starting to see
a shift
i was lonely in college too you know i
went across the country it took it was
really hard to sort of settle into my
new college environment but i was able
to do it because
i was able to be in community with
others and the social media that our
kids were raised on is actually
anti-social because it's not happening
in community you are on your phone by
yourself you're solitary and what we
find is that in high school kids aren't
leaving the house anymore they sit at
home and text they're not dating as much
anymore they're not driving as much
anymore they don't go out and hang out
the mall they don't build these
interpersonal communities they're all
virtual and because of that when they
get to a place like college where they
can build interpersonal communities
they're actually ill-equipped to do so
and we're teaching them how to do it but
i'm stealing ideas from like my kids
preschool you know coloring book
sessions like we put out the coloring
books kids come flocking you know
friendship classes you know but we're so
downstream how do we think upstream like
how do we think about the root causes of
this because by the time we get them
there this is 18 to 22. these are
band-aids on without actually looking at
the structural element right my son is
14 almost 15 and
really struggled uh and struggles with
electronics and
really ideates on playing games and
watching videos and everything is carrot
in the stick for him if he gets screen
time basically and
we sent him to the summer camp that was
a month-long camping no electronics and
i'm telling you he's a different person
coming home from that sure
one month in the woods without any
electronics he's utterly transformed and
the connections he made with those kids
are like like deep heart connections and
it showed him maybe for the first time
that he could have those relationships
without technology mediating them
and without that experience how does he
know how to translate that in future his
future life
[Music]
rain i'm gonna go on a limb here and
guess that you don't get enough fruit
and veggies in your diet damn straight i
mean it's hard i don't i mean none of us
do and this year my goal is to change
that and that's why i'm keeping my
freezer stocked with daily harvest daily
harvest is the easiest way to get more
fruits and veggies into my day every day
they got my back with delicious food
that's good for me and
good for the planet daily harvest
delivers delicious harvest bowls
flatbreads smoothies and more all built
on organic fruits and vegetables right
to your door and it conveniently stays
fresh in your freezer i just got an
entire pack the other day and like
there's basically nothing left here so
they got this like
banana cashew oats and almond chocolate
like desserty thing that's like that's
like an oat bowl kind of thing right
well they got the dessert version
they've got the opal with the
strawberries they got this kale and
sweet potato flatbread you know i'm a
huge smoothie fan and they have these
instant smoothies like you just pour
them in your blender add a little like
oat milk and water and some ice and boom
you've just got a smoothie and
amazing flavors i had one yesterday it
was incredible daily harvest takes
literally minutes to prepare never uses
preservatives added sugar or artificial
anything and that goes for everything
they've got so many delicious options
for every time of day daily harvest is
all about preserving and protecting
earth for current and future generations
to come from their recyclable and
compostable packaging to investing in
organic farming practices and reducing
food waste you can feel good about the
choices you're making physically and for
the environment daily harvest makes it
easy to feel good about what i'm doing
for myself and the planet go to
dailyharvest.com
milkshake to get up to forty dollars off
your first box that's daily harvest dot
com slash milkshake for up to forty
dollars off your first box
dailyharvest.com
milkshake
if i may shift it a little bit varun you
have a fascinating background because
you grew up hindu but you've also had an
in-depth study of buddhism and been in a
buddhist ashram monastery monastery from
that perspective
what's the spiritual solution
to
this
uh loneliness and you know not talking
necessarily about electronics but what's
what can you bring to that so i think
there's two things one is of course
mindfulness has become a big buzzword in
secular life uh universities
corporations et cetera we're running
probably the largest mindfulness
initiative in american higher education
we're training seven thousand people a
year what's that like tell us what so we
have 50 classes um throughout the year
that are free and open to students we
have um
drop-in groups we have workshops we have
an app um
what i found is that i can't keep up
with the demand i got like 300 kids on
the wait list for the self-compassion
class because what no one told them they
could be compassionate to themselves and
it's like this revelation for that
that's amazing but what i think
mindfulness is so popular on our campus
is because we give students permission
to turn off their phones just like you
gave your son permission to
not use this phone for a month it's
almost like they need permission because
that's their de facto it's like an
appendage right 50 of young adults say
internet connectivity is as important to
them as food air and shelter right this
is an essential wow yeah this is the new
this is gen z right so
it's like fasting you almost have to
have permission or a reason to fast
otherwise you're not gonna actually do
it
the second though the most important
thing i think is something that isn't
buddhist per se but is connected to all
of our faith traditions and that is just
how do you build a community you know
the most important study on this is the
grant study um which is out of harvard
in 1935 it was the longest study of
human behavior in history
in 1935 they started falling around 7
200 undergraduates for 75 years
and they
studied these undergraduates to see what
conditions lead to human happiness and
they studied salary they studied height
they studied weight education relations
you know all the sort of things that one
would think lead to success and at the
end of their lives these
undergraduates told the researchers that
the most important thing for them in
their own flourishing was the depth of
their loving relationships period that
was it all you need is love that's what
the beatles told us 50 years ago how
deep are your loving relationships
that's what makes us human that's what
causes us to feel as though we live a
life worth leading on a college campus
with 50 000 students 140 countries 50
states and 90 religious groups you would
think that that is the ideal place to
build community the ideal place to learn
and grow and love each other but i see
it as being much much more fragmented
than that partly because
it's so hard for students to build a
community outside of a virtual one it
seems so obvious the the answer to
loneliness is hanging out with people
yeah hang out with people that's right
listen the other thing i'll talk about
and i know we have a particular point of
view it's not a joke but we have a
baha'i muslim hindu sitting in a room
together uh is the loss of religion
amongst gen z i expect at least almost
50 of my first-year students will not be
affiliated with religion 50
in 1950 it was two percent of americans
now it's 50 percent of young adults
that's not changing we are moving to a
society that is less and less
religiously affiliated and historically
religion has been the place which
provides community meaning and purpose
and ethical worldview a celebration of
life events um it's a way to uh it's
kind of the whole point ritual myth this
is what it means to be human how to make
sense of our experience i tell students
it's okay to walk away from religion
okay to walk away from god but what are
you replacing that with right if you
walk away from religion don't walk away
from meaning community purpose joy
gratitude but we don't have necessarily
the infrastructure in this new world of
ours to replace religion uh with
anything in a way that makes sense it's
kind of we're in a
a test phase right now we're throwing
out a bunch of ideas can hip-hop be a
religion can sports be a religion we're
testing these ideas but uh i think
that's another thing um
a recent study i read which i almost
couldn't believe i had to reread it said
that if you have an intergenerational
spiritual experience that means if you
go to a gudvara or a mosque or a
synagogue or a church with your parents
or grandparents growing up you are 80
percent less likely to be depressed as a
young adult
so when we have an epidemic of
depression on college campuses and
almost half of our students are not
affiliated with religion
you know listen correlation doesn't
equal causality but i see some kind of
link so i've been trying to think about
how to recreate a secular kind of
structure that replaces formal religion
but gives students what they would
otherwise get from those isn't that what
usc football is though that's what it is
the whole point listen i i when i got to
usc people like oh you're the dean of
religious and spiritual life well you
should know the real religion on this
campus is football and i was like ha ha
until i went to a game i'm like yeah
you're right this is myth this is ritual
this is agony and ecstasy this is you
know people with funny hats shared
experience shared experience
intergenerational
and you see the trojan family at its
best at a football game here's a thought
so i think i think that's very
interesting sort of what the um
solution could possibly be and i think
it's going to be a number of things like
we've said but should we just maybe
take for granted the fact that we are
basically becoming a human race
that is just going to be more isolated
and more lonely that this is what we're
moving towards is this our future this
is our future and instead of instead of
trying to stop an unstoppable force
just learn to
deal with it like figure out how to how
we deal with this kind of loneliness and
you know
just but here's the problem with that
rosa i hear where you're coming from but
varun tell me what you were talking
about in terms of suicide you know ten
percent of our students across the
country uh
have had a thought of suicide over the
last year five percent have made a plan
five percent so on my campus of fifty
thousand students on any beautiful sunny
day where the you know southern
california football games everyone's
walking through literally a college
brochure of the idyllic experience i got
2500 kids who are thinking about their
own death 2500 who have made a plan and
when we have suicide when students die
by suicide on campuses we have to be
concerned about suicidal contagion other
students
this is the stuff that keeps me up at
night the numbers are kind of intense
personally have have seen that increase
in that spike in the number of suicides
you've been called on right to a go to
suicide attempts and i have i listen
i've probably overseen more
student memorial services than anyone in
the united states over the last 10 years
i used to be stoic you know i used to be
strong and then i had a kid and i can't
be anymore every month i'm we you know
i'm crying and grieving with a parent
and when that death seem is seemingly
preventable either it's by suicide
homicide accidental drug overdose or
poor decision making based on the
overconsumption of alcohol when it's a
seemingly preventable death
uh we have guilt counseling it's not
just grief counseling because other you
know students on our communities like
they feel guilty that i saw this coming
i should have intervened right
so i see what the impact is on on humans
on communities
and it's devastating so
how
can we become more resistant
to
loneliness
you need to have
five people in your life who have your
back you don't need to have a thousand
friends online you need to have five
real friends in life who you meet with
who you hang out with who you can tell
anything to
research tells us that if we have a
happy friend we're 30 more likely to be
happy if our happy friend has a happy
friend we're also more likely to be
happy that there's a force multiplier
effect with healthy relationships people
say i'll show you who you're going to be
if you show me your five best friends i
never really knew what that meant and
now i totally see it i think we have to
understand that we can only have about
120 meaningful relationships in our life
at any given time
to be perfectly frank five seems like a
tall order three what about three i tell
my students three i feel like i've got
three i tell myself you got two in this
room
does your wife count because she has no
choice she has to be your friend yeah
yeah i think i think i could say i have
three friends that are like
they got my back
yeah let's get them on the show and see
what they say that's right
[Music]
lightning round life's big questions
varun are you ready
when do you feel most connected with the
universe ironically when i'm alone when
i'm on a bike or on i'm hiking and i'm
with my thoughts and i'm
in the world in nature when i'm alone
describe your soul in 10 words or less
um
it's your soul
in reflection ooh
that's good big one that's a bumper
sticker what is your biggest fear
inadequacy as a father what would you
say is your life's big question i think
it's always been who am i and what do
you think's the purpose of your life i
think we're service driven
purpose
is to be there for others what's the
hardest thing you've ever had to do
study sanskrit
what brings you joy
um my relationships especially with my
family but also my students i'm in it
for the students
what would you want your final meal to
be indian maybe from one of my favorite
restaurants
wrong fessen june
what's your hope for the next generation
that they find meaning purpose joy and
gratitude in their lives in the same way
that we were able to when was the last
time you ugly cried
ugly cried what is that
you know it's been it's it's been too
long
but it was probably with one of our
campus tragedies in the last year
would you like us to make you ugly cry
maybe after this uh what's the one thing
you know for sure i'm not sure i know
anything for sure that's the right
answer
varun sony such a an amazing
honor to talk to you today and i mean
that because
this
issue anxiety loneliness depression
suicidal ideation with young people is
just breaking my heart and it's breaking
hearts all across america people need to
think about this dig into this
deal with it
live it ponder it and get involved and
this conversation is helping that happen
thank you thank you for having me this
was amazing and thank you for the work
you're doing
that was i have to be honest with you
that that was kind of depressing it was
depressing well all these lonely kids
like kids who don't know how to make
friends it's just i mean it depresses
the [ __ ] out of me yeah and the thing
that really sparked my thinking was the
fact that there's a lot of discussion
around
anxiety and depression and even suicide
but the idea that loneliness might be at
the root of all of these things
disconnectedness
um is
is really revelatory uh maybe that's the
symptom we need to treat i don't know
but it just it reminded me of something
kind of even more depressing which is
these poor like millennials and gen z's
who you know are saying they don't have
any friends it just gets harder guys
make friends now
because when when you get older it's not
it's just not going to get any easier to
make friends
get off of social media and make friends
speaking of that get on social media and
tell us how you make friends yes social
media is a
virulent scourge
against people connecting with one
another uh it's the devil so what we're
asking you to do is get on your social
media
and uh write us hashtag metaphysical at
rayne wilson reza aslan we want to hear
from you hashtag metaphysical
have you felt lonely what do you do
about it how do we make friends how do
we make friends later in life
uh what can we do
to solve this epidemic of loneliness
amongst our younger peoples we are here
for you
as you know
uh when you rate and review on apple
podcasts if you leave a life's big
question we will track you down and ask
you to come on the show and speak to us
and guess what
we have a very special guest this may be
the guest that has
zoomed in from the furthest point away
from us on the globe we had a we had a
glaswegian remember yeah but but brazil
is farther away than than scotland don't
you think well maybe i don't know kelly
from brazil welcome hi kelly thanks for
for calling in hello everybody hello
kelly from brazil you have the least
brazilian name i have ever heard in my
life it's kelly with an eye it sounds
like you're an undergrad at indiana
university exactly most cheerleaders are
named kelly with an eye how did your
parents give you the name kelly with an
i
i don't know it might be hollywood
influence
i don't know
kelly mcgillis
kelly regis and kelly kelly clarkson
maybe all right what is your question
okay my
biggest my life's biggest question is
uh according to david
attenborough a timberwold
button yeah yeah primates they are not
very adapted to living in arctic lands
cold weather snow stuff like that
he said that
because they evolved in tropical lands
right like south america sure
so
since we homo sapiens we are clearly
primates
are the helix the of the headless type
by the way
wouldn't be smarter
are sustainable
to limit ourselves to living in
tropolins rather than arctic or arid
lands zones
what do you think i mean it certainly
would be more enjoyable
sure
it's currently like 56 57 in la and i'm
miserable yeah it's it's freezing out it
is freezing outside it got down it got
down into the 40s
40s which for los angeles listen kelly
you know for a good hundred thousand
years that's what humanity did was just
hang around in the scrub lands of africa
and then slowly ever so slowly started
pushing north and in other directions
and um and there was an ice age in there
somewhere um
and yeah and i don't i don't get it i
don't understand
i don't understand humanity because this
idea that there's tribes
living in like
gnome
alaska or baffin island
and it's freezing cold why don't they
just are like hey it's warmer the
further south let's just go south
and then there's probably a tribe there
but then they just there there were
hardly any people on the planet and
there was like a couple million people
on the entire planet just keep going
south guys you don't you don't have to
live up there i don't get it reza please
explain well as you know i moonlight as
an evolutionary biologist
um that's one of my many many
uh
expertise but look i it's it's
interesting that you brought up primates
like you're absolutely right you know
primates uh
evolved you know to adapt to a
particular kind of environment which is
why they don't do as well in other kinds
of environment but we're homo sapiens
are primates we evolved in the same uh
environment shouldn't we
uh have a hard time adapting to colder
environments but aha there's the rub
right it's that the thing that separates
us from primates is that we have that
the social brain as it's called the
social brain like we have the ability
to
communicate
uh
uh information that allows for adjusting
and adapting um you know the creation of
tools that are necessary to help us to
adapt to
uh you know whatever situation we find
ourselves be it an environmental
situation or a different kind of
situation it's why like our communities
could have gone from as rain said you
know a hundred thousand years in which
all we are is just our kin group you
know maybe a dozen people together to
suddenly expanding to villages that have
thousands and thousands of people city
states that have tens of thousands of
people
because
we have the capacity to communicate
information that allows for quick
adaptation like if i discover something
that allows me to adapt i can
communicate that thing to another
individual in a very rapid way that
allows that individual to adapt and so
on and so on and so on and it's like
that's the whole
purpose of why we were able to
survive
in these sort of frigid areas you know
where neanderthals were about to die off
you know completely um
it because we had the ability to use our
brains to create tools necessary to
adapt to whatever environment we found
ourselves in and then you know the rest
is as they say paleolithic history right
then we just kind of went everywhere
like east and west and south and we're
going to like make boats and go into the
you know tropical regions and uh
in the you know polynesia et cetera et
cetera and everywhere we went
as one individual learned a new
adaptation they communicated it to
another individual and it just
kind of spread like wildfire in a way
that isn't as endemic
to you know primates who
uh arose in very similar circumstances
and context as as we did
thank you very much everybody thank you
thank you now why am i even here first
of all
well i said but also why didn't us these
socially brained people go up to the
inuit and say guys it's way warmer down
there
that's right it's way warmer even in
like ottawa even in ottawa it's way
warmer than baffin island come on down
and there's like nuts and berries
what nuts there are plants you see that
little piece of grass it's like a bigger
than that plant and there's nuts and
berries you can just eat off of the
plant like we're out of here
[ __ ] this ice fishing [ __ ] best
thing about nuts and berries they can't
kill you back that's right what do you
think kelly would you you got an opinion
about this
yeah my problem is that we have a we
have to learn a lot of
tree
you know
to keep ourselves safe
yeah arctic lands
so burn burn tree it's not sustainable
yeah we burn trees we have to like wear
animal skins and even then it's not
doing that well
one thing that i do think is super
fascinating to this this might get cut
from the episode because it's a bit of a
tangent but i always loved it is that
you know we used to teach our kids
that homo sapiens wiped out the
neanderthals right that the that homo
sapiens came out from these tropical
lands and they had better tools and
bigger brains
uh they didn't they they made it
true they did not have bigger brains
that's an actual i should not have said
that it's true the neanderthals had
bigger brains but now we know bigger
doesn't necessarily mean more useful but
whatever the point is
that the idea was that you know we just
kind of slaughtered homo sapiens just
slaughtered all the neanderthals
but we made it with them but that's true
rain is right now we know that that is
false that's not true we've been
teaching
our kids lies
that in reality what we did is we boned
the neanderthals we were like hey baby
they're very [ __ ] you know they're
thicker they're bigger warmer there you
go maybe that's what it is kelly is that
nice i don't know all these big-bodied
men and women yes why go back down to
the tropics and to this day women like
hairy men
to be more sustainable
i stopped burning so much freeze and
coal
and
carbon dioxide
talk to your brazilian friends about
stopping burning the amazon please uh
speaking of burning trees so
we we are like diverse so
a lot of people don't agree with that
i don't agree with that a lot of people
don't agree i'm i'm pretty sure that the
office fans
for example don't agree with that most
of them we should start a office fans to
save the amazon weirdly enough the
office is really big in brazil isn't it
i think so because brazil is big so it's
like proportional
and we need to laugh
you know to fight against
anxiety and depression that's my case
for example uh before we go down an
office rabbit hole thank you kelly
i i thank you guys very much listen up
folks want more of life's big questions
find us on the social medias at reza
aslan and rayne wilson and on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and instagram at
metaphysical milkshake let us know your
life's big questions we just might
explore them on a future episode and of
course you can always leave those
lifespeed questions on your positive
apple podcast review
rain and reza out
need to create an app a friend make
friends app
you know just friends app no no sex
stuff we could call it friendster
friendster i love that trademark that
please amy are you on there amy yes can
you secure that domain name please and
that app yes princeton okay that's a
great idea i love the name yes i'm sure
nobody's ever used it before very catchy
friendster.net thanks again to our guest
today varun sony till next time
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick demaria
hashem self and dj lubell cast media is
the production and distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by joshua harris original music is
composed by jeff tang
it was produced by amy s choi and
rebecca lehrer of the mashup americans
associate producers are jocelyn gonzalez
lindsey crowderwill sarah pellegrini
mary phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
[Music]
how many friends do you have you know
what's funny i feel like
you know the older i get the less time i
have for friends you have so many kids
you have like you know 11 kids so many
damn kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you